he's Shaquille O'Neal the big podcast
with Shaq it's on podcast 1 and Shaq
joins us now good morning Jacques how
are you man I don't know you you were
terrible get your turkey middle of the
oven fix me that joke don't say it to
you McLovin did you actually text Shaq
that joke I did we text back and forth
every day all night long or uber yeah
that's good subject thank you that's the
only reason why we wanted to talk to you
so you can deliver that letter what do
you have in for breakfast today have you
had breakfast oh no not yet I'm going to
be on my way up to New York all right
what would breakfast consistent for you
argh one almac sausage cheese but glass
in the glass I would use two bottles of
water but you don't go crazy it like you
don't do big meals no I don't do this my
problem my wall my problem used to be on
right now but uh Thursday rocks it
worked out jealous but more
probabilities to be sandwiches or just I
was you know I'm sitting next to
Berkeley and I see his belly plate over
shirt I said to myself I can decide
forward so I haven't been in these
houses in the world
so this chicken fish stop it if you play
Berkeley one-on-one right now it would
have been a serve during what is
believed as you going to over tomorrow
all the way to quit when when you're
asked about who do people say who's the
best big man of all time do they ask you
okay
where where do you rank all right I'll
put Marcel probably four or five okay
now are you being humble or do you
really feel that way
well I've been I'm being humble just had
a a lot of people don't pay homage to
the people before them so as you know
it's Russell was was the father of all
big male action choice bacon so Russell
was the father 11 championships
then Kareem
six and then I could probably play
myself three or four but a coupon I got
the better with me it's all we got to do
that so I'll put it three it up with
myself for if you came in right now how
different well you make me three hundred
be working tough at all but I'm not
gonna change what's doing this because
everybody else's shoot jumpers you shoot
jumpers just tells me that you don't
like the punishment about the kitchen
and you just want to take and pop the
shoot jumpers now that's not a big more
play to get yeah as you know you know a
lot of these guys now a product of their
environment what I mean by that they
wash up watch it card that Duncan the
Biscay and those guys who have the
ability to step up now guys are you know
making out their first option keber
feels sorry for a defender
never and I try to put my boat in his
face area so he thought I was coming
okay well that leads me to what is
allowable what is part of the game and
leads me to Pachulia what did you see
with that play on Kawhi Leonard okay as
a big guy when you over extend and put
your leg out like that it will always be
a 50-50 chance that the guy will
sprained his ankle and then the other 50
that he won't know guys know this is the
unwritten rule that you're not supposed
to get off your shooter and publish
amazing blow to a great point he had a
two-step with a extra leap calls out and
when you stick your leg out like that
this simple you know is always revision
some guys make that part of the defense
what every player knows and every big
guy though actually guy would be Creek
Hill the bigger your feet on a closer on
to the guy the higher the chances buddy
come down on the ankle do you think
patchouli is a dirty blanket
I wouldn't say dirty player he's
physical alright I think I think he uh I
think he knew what he was doing on that
place
talking to Shaquille O'Neal NBA on TNT
also a podcast one you can hear the big
podcast with Shaq I remember the first
time I interviewed you I think we were
at the Marriott in Marina del Rey and
you're with your dad but I wondered
about you know Sarge
his influence on you and then you see
lebar ball with Lonzo ball could you
have ever seen your dad have more of an
influence like lebar ball was having
with Lanza on your career my dad had a
powerful influence but he understood
that you know from age two from age 18
16 years of them raised me as a
responsible young man you know teach me
my trials and tribulations teach me
about other players before me their
failures fill out you don't know that
when I NBA player myself I would get
trouble I have to compile like you know
my dad will come in with the paper they
said you need this you can never do that
so he was definitely influenced by the
uncle David really say you know what
you're mad you learned your business how
you learn and I'm here to support you as
anybody travel Metro did he support you
or did he push you uh he pushed me and
he reported me you know he wasn't you
know he was a he was inside the house
extroverted person but when you mess
with him a resident families and he can
get loud you get crazy oh he was a drill
sergeant so he only knew one way and I
was yelling I was a lot of energy and
you know that I was good but you know I
came out and you know I had my plan laid
out you start crying because you know
what you're a man you got this convinced
me huh and and I never needed him to
speak for me like I like you know they
are PR ball garlic I never hear him
speak to does father answered all the
questions that we reading lately but
it's not a we situation is uh your son
situation and then you know if my son
ever gets it up to the point where you
see something a hell of a player or top
player hopefully you will fo hopefully
you won't ever hear my name because I'm
gonna say you know everybody I raise you
the right way I've been there and done
it before you need some advice up here
but I'm not gonna say a do this mm mm
that's supposed to lift 50 kids he's
supposed to live for you kids
if Lonzo ball would go to the Lakers
Shaq is that a good thing
or
anything uh something that magics don't
have to do it well you know I think of
the other great good thing for the city
that was a great line at home in heaven
that was a great line right over to
friendzone very correct also also makes
people look better as you don't isn't a
great player like he's a great passing
great ball handler big size big body but
you know something that magic and my
good friend Jimmy does laughs Achilles
but you know what I don't mess around I
don't you know that things like that I
definitely patrol if you were playing in
Lonzo ball came in with all this
attention surrounding him would you do
anything different to him will players
do anything different to him playing
against every big guy you know horrible
garlic for the ha I think we lost Shaq
if he's going to the airport fritzy it's
okay I just wanted to ask him about the
Celtics in the cast if if he can
convince me the Celtics can make this
interesting we'll see
I think he's officially going there 14
see if you can get him back if not then
don't worry about it
I'll text him dead oh yeah
you never hear the end of that one I
didn't know that you and Shankar you
know pen pals here well this week I've
been jealous Will Ferrell gave a
shout-out to fritzy singing voice
yesterday on the show and I haven't
heard the end of that now I got Shaq
texting me yeah well good for you by the
way McLovin is going to take a victory
lap because of something that Tom Brady
had to say and it's something McLovin
has been saying about Tom Brady Shaq eww
back with us where you get your phone
click on our bill to blame Fred Segal
over there you go over top of the rules
correct the wrestler life are ok
convinced me how the Celtics make this
interesting with the Cavs
they have the home court advantage I got
to get both these games you know you got
to put the Cavs in the hole and I mean
know what personal the Cavs are not
going to get tight if they've been in
our situation but
got to put them in the hole because
never know what happens you know
somebody who can heard talk about fit
and then you know somebody can go down
and you're up to kilogram and then you
come home and ended uh what at home
where do you have LeBron G do you rank
players I know Barkley says LeBron can't
be in his top five which i think is
silly but do you know the characters
yeah do you think he can I think you
have to I think you have to rate players
in their time you know I would like to
have the top 50 list yeah the hot dress
yes bill like that listen you know it's
hard to replace our magicks I'm Mike
Malone all these guys prosit a player
but I'm biased when it comes to things
like that because always I always put
the guys with Flores as the ones that
paved the way for us Ron's definitely a
top 10 player but ah no it's hard for
him
we you know you don't put him before
he'll put him before magic he'll put it
before bike I'll put it before Colby I
don't know the answer that but I do know
he's a fabulous player he's a true
definition of a great player making
everyone around a banner ad he's always
done it the right way down here in the
trouble he's family guys in community
guys so but Mike and dr. Jay have always
done by to Gus and nobody can replace
her there's no way LeBron even if he got
to the same number of titles as Mike or
even got to five that you wouldn't put
him up there on that pedestal I never
said he was not up there he's up there
but your side is equal to those guys is
he better than those guys now this is
barbershop talk and a lot of people
attitude makes play a terrific obsession
but me being older guy nobody didn't
like my can i play with Kobe and when I
let him go he continued to do it in
Tomaso to him watching Magic Bird a call
and poppy and all those guys kind of
tough and you should do a barbershop
show
I sure yeah you should just you know do
cut hair
I'll go there I can do bulges and big
lovin I'll give you free down stretch
airball for your favorite charity
there you go McLovin $3,000 to your
favorite charity Shaq will shave you
bald
let's make it five ghosts larger for
deal except that I don't actually know
if I follow through with this when do
you trace it yet you don't trust Jack
paying you or you don't trust him come
over here
no I trust Jack both but I think I would
look so awful bald yeah but you just
wear a head you have a nice shirt you
ever I should write both I do it for
charity and I'm not gonna take it add a
little trouble I like her I love that I
love that
so I'm Pablo that's very nice you Shack
safe travels up to New York I was great
to talk to you the big popular with with
Shaq podcast one and I know Ernie
Johnson got a lot of credit for his
Shack and personation those those rebels
is it better than mine I've heard yours
familiars dead Patrick
shut the hell up that's pretty good well
safe travels in a groove
Thank You chef
that Shack and there we go are you going
to shave mclubbe and Ted $4,000 to your
favorite charity oh you have a very nice
okay Andre the Giant Adina Mikkel have a
go up on the roof and connect the red
wire and the black wire the kicker is
I'm just gonna pop up whenever shave
your head the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
you